Chris Anderson: Shane, give us
a snapshot of you growing up
and what on Earth led you to get
interested in artificial intelligence?
Shane Legg: Well, I got my first
home computer on my 10th birthday,
and I --
this was before the internet
and everything.
So you couldn't just go
and surf the web and so on.
You had to actually make stuff
yourself and program.
And so I started programming,
and I discovered that in this computer
there was a world,
I could create a world,
I could create little agents
that would run around
and chase each other
and do things and so on.
And I could sort of,
bring this whole universe to life.
And there was  sort of that spark
of creativity that really captivated me
and sort of, I think
that was really the seeds
of my interest that later grew
into an interest
in artificial intelligence.
CA: Because in your standard education,
you had some challenges there.
SL: Yeah, I was dyslexic as a child.
And so they were actually
going to hold me back a year
when I was 10 years old,
and they sent me off
to get my IQ tested to sort of,
you know, assess how bad the problem was.
And they discovered I had
an exceptionally high IQ.
And then they were a little bit confused
about what was going on.
And fortunately, at that time,
there was somebody in the town I lived in
who knew how to test for dyslexia.
And it turns out I wasn't actually
of limited intelligence.
I was dyslexic, and that was the issue.
CA: You had reason
from an early age to believe
that our standard assumptions
about intelligence might be off a bit.
SL: Well, I had reason, from an early age,
to sometimes doubt authority.
(Laughter)
You know, if the teacher thinks
you're dumb, maybe it's not true.
Maybe there are other things going on.
But I think it also created in me
an interest in intelligence
when I sort of had
that experience as a child.
CA: So you're credited by many
as coining the term
“artificial general intelligence,” AGI.
Tell us about 2001, how that happened.
SL: Yeah, so I was approached
by someone called Ben Goertzel
who I'd actually been working with,
and he was going to write a book,
and he was thinking
about a book on AI systems
that would be much more
general and capable,
rather than focusing
on very narrow things.
And he was thinking
about a title for the book.
So I suggested to him, "If you're
interested in very general systems,
call it artificial general intelligence."
And so he went with that.
And then him and various other people
started using the term online
and the internet,
and then it sort of became
popularized from there.
We later discovered there was
someone called Mike Garrod,
who published a paper in a security
nanotech journal in '97.
So he is actually the first person
to have used the term.
But it turns out he pretty much meant
the same thing as us anyway.
CA: It was kind of an idea
whose time had come,
to recognize the potential here.
I mean, you made an early prediction
that many people thought was bonkers.
What was that?
SL: Well, in about 2001,
a similar time to when I suggested
this term artificial general intelligence,
I read a book by Ray Kurzweil, actually,
"Age of Spiritual Machines,"
and I concluded that he was
fundamentally right,
that computation was likely to grow
exponentially for at least a few decades,
and the amount of data in the world
would grow exponentially
for a few decades.
And so I figured
that if that was going to happen,
then the value of extremely
scalable algorithms
that could harness
all this data and computation
were going to be very high.
And then I also figured
that in the mid 2020s,
it would be possible then,
if we had these highly
scalable algorithms,
to train artificial intelligence systems
on far more data than a human
would experience in a lifetime.
And so as a result of that,
you can find it on my blog
from about 2009
I think it's the first time
I publicly talked about it,
I predicted a 50 percent
chance of AGI by 2028.
I still believe that today.
CA: That's still your date.
How did you define AGI back then,
and has your definition changed?
SL: Yeah, I didn't have a particularly
precise definition at the beginning.
It was really just an idea of systems
that would just be far more general.
So rather than just playing
Go or chess or something,
rather than actually be able to do many,
many different things.
The definition I use now
is that it's a system
that can do all the cognitive
kinds of tasks
that people can do, possibly more,
but at least it can do
the sorts of cognitive tasks
that people can typically do.
CA: So talk about just
the founding of DeepMind
and the interplay between you
and your cofounders.
SL: Right. So I went to London
to the place called the Gatsby Unit,
which studies theoretical neuroscience
and machine learning.
And I was interested in learning
the relationships
between what we understand about the brain
and what we know from machine learning.
So that seemed like a really good place.
And I met Demis Hassabis there.
He had the same postdoc supervisor as me,
and we got talking.
And he convinced me
that it was the time
to start a company then.
That was in 2009 we started talking.
And I was a little bit skeptical.
I thought AGI was still
a bit too far away,
but he thought the time was right,
so we decided to go for it.
And then a friend of his
was Mustafa Suleyman.
CA: And specifically,
one of the goals of the company
was to find a pathway to AGI?
SL: Absolutely.
On our first business plan
that we were circulating
when we were looking
for investors in 2010,
it had one sentence
on the front cover and it said,
"Build the world's first artificial
general intelligence."
So that was right in from the beginning.
CA: Even though you knew
that building that AGI might actually have
apocalyptic consequences
in some scenarios?
SL: Yeah.
So it's a deeply
transformative technology.
I believe it will happen.
I think that, you know,
these algorithms can be understood
and they will be understood at the time.
And I think that intelligence
is fundamentally
an incredibly valuable thing.
Everything around us at the moment --
the building we’re in,
the words I’m using, the concepts we have,
the technology around us --
you know, all of these things
are being affected by intelligence.
So having intelligence in machines
is an incredibly valuable
thing to develop.
And so I believe it is coming.
Now when a very, very
powerful technology arises,
there can be a range
of different outcomes.
Things could go very, very well,
but there is a possibility things
can go badly as well.
And that was something I was aware of
also from about 20 years ago.
CA: So talk about, as DeepMind developed,
was there a moment where you really felt,
"My goodness, we're onto
something unbelievably powerful?"
Like, was it AlphaGo, that whole story,
or what was the moment for you?
SL: Yeah, there were many
moments over the years.
One was when we did the Atari games.
Have you seen those videos
where we had an algorithm
that could learn to play multiple games
without being programmed
for any specific game?
There were some exciting moments there.
Go, of course, was a really
exciting moment.
But I think the thing that's really
captured my imagination,
a lot of people's imagination,
is the phenomenal scaling
of language models in recent years.
I think we can see they're systems
that really can start
to do some meaningful fraction
of the cognitive tasks that people can do.
CA: Now, you were working on those models,
but were you, to some extent, blindsided
by OpenAI's, sort of,
sudden unveiling of ChatGPT?
SL: Right.
We were working on them and you know,
the transformer model
was invented in Google,
and we had teams who were building big
transformer language models and so on.
CA: Google acquired DeepMind
at some point in this journey.
SL: Yeah, exactly.
And so what I didn't expect
was just how good a model could get
training purely on text.
I thought you would
need more multimodality.
You'd need images, you'd need sound,
you'd need video and things like that.
But due to the absolutely
vast quantities of text,
it can sort of compensate
for these things to an extent.
I still think you see aspects of this.
I think language models
tend to be weak in areas
that are not easily expressed in text.
But I don’t think
this is a fundamental limitation.
I think we're going to see these language
models expanding into video
and images and sound and all these things,
and these things will be overcome in time.
CA: So talk to us, Shane,
about the things that you, at this moment,
passionately feel that the world needs
to be thinking about more cogently.
SL: Right.
So I think that very, very powerful,
very intelligent artificial
intelligence is coming.
I think that this is very, very likely.
I don't think it's coming today.
I don't think it's coming next
year or the year after.
It's probably a little bit
further out than that.
CA: 2028?
SL: 2028, that's a 50 percent chance.
So, you know, if it doesn't
happen in 2028,
I'm not going to be surprised, obviously.
CA: And when you say powerful,
I mean there's already
powerful AI out there.
But you're saying basically a version
of artificial general
intelligence is coming.
SL: Yeah.
CA: So give us a picture
of what that could look like.
SL: Well, if you had
an artificial general intelligence,
you could do all sorts of amazing things.
Just like human intelligence is able
to do many, many amazing things.
So it's not really about a specific thing,
that's the whole point of the generality.
But to give you one example,
we developed the system AlphaFold,
which will take a protein and compute,
basically, the shape of that protein.
And that enables you to do
all sorts of research
into understanding biological processes,
developing medicines
and all kinds of things like that.
Now, if you had an AGI system,
instead of requiring
what we had at DeepMind,
about roughly 30 world-class scientists
working for about three years
to develop that,
maybe you could develop that
with just a team
of a handful of scientists in one year.
So imagine these, sort of,
AlphaFold-level developments
taking place around the world
on a regular basis.
This is the sort of thing
that AGI could enable.
CA: So within months of AGI
being with us, so to speak,
it's quite possible that some
of the scientific challenges
that humans have wrestled with
for decades, centuries, if you like,
will start to tumble in rapid succession.
SL: Yeah, I think it'll open up
all sorts of amazing possibilities.
And it could be really
a golden age of humanity
where human intelligence,
which is aided and extended
with machine intelligence,
enables us to do all sorts
of fantastic things
and solve problems that previously
were just intractable.
CA: So let's come back to that.
But I think you also,
you're not like,
an irredeemable optimist only,
you see a potential for it to go
very badly in a different direction.
Talk about what that pathway
could look like.
SL: Well, yeah, I want to explain.
I don't believe the people
who are sure that it's going
to go very well,
and I don't believe the people
who are sure that it’s going
to go very, very badly.
Because what we’re talking about
is an incredibly profound transition.
It's like the arrival of human
intelligence in the world.
This is another intelligence
arriving in the world.
And so it is an incredibly
deep transition,
and we do not fully understand
all the implications
and consequences of this.
And so we can't be certain
that it's going to be this,
that or the other thing.
So we have to be open-minded
about what may happen.
I have some optimism because I think
that if you want to make a system safe,
you need to understand
a lot about that system.
You can't make an airplane safe
if you don't know
about how airplanes work.
So as we get closer to AGI,
we will understand more
and more about these systems,
and we will see more ways
to make these systems safe,
make highly ethical AI systems.
But there are many things
we don't understand about the future.
So I have to accept that there is
a possibility that things may go badly
because I don't know
what's going to happen.
I can't know that about the future
in such a big change.
And even if the probability of something
going bad is quite small,
we should take this extremely seriously.
CA: Paint a scenario
of what going bad could look like.
SL: Well, it's hard to do
because you're talking about systems
that potentially have superhuman
intelligence, right?
So there are many ways in which
things would go bad in the world.
People sometimes point to, I don't know,
engineered pathogens, right?
Maybe a superintelligence could
design an engineered pathogen.
It could be much more mundane things.
Maybe with AGI, you know,
it gets used to destabilize
democracy in the world,
with, you know, propaganda
or all sorts of other things like that.
We don't know --
CA: That one might already have happened.
SL: There might be happening
a bit already.
But, you know, there may
be a lot more of this
if we have more powerful systems.
So there are many ways in which
societies can be destabilized.
And you can see that in the history books.
CA: I mean, Shane, if you
could have asked all humans,
say, 15 years ago, OK,
we can open a door here,
and opening this door could lead
to the best-ever outcomes for humanity.
But there's also a meaningful chance,
let's say it's more than five percent,
that we could actually
destroy our civilization.
I mean, isn't there a chance
that most people would have actually said,
"Don't you dare open that damn door.
Let's wait."
SL: If I had a magic wand
and I could slow things down,
I would use that magic wand, but I don't.
There are dozens of companies,
well, there's probably
10 companies in the world now
that can develop the most
cutting-edge models, including, I think,
some national intelligence services
who have secret projects doing this.
And then there's, I don't know,
dozens of companies that can develop
something that's a generation behind.
And remember, intelligence
is incredibly valuable.
It's incredibly useful.
We're doing this
because we can see all kinds of value
that can be created in this
for all sorts of reasons.
How do you stop this process?
I don't see any realistic plan
that I've heard of,
of stopping this process.
Maybe we can --
I think we should think
about regulating things.
I think we should do things like this
as we do with every powerful technology.
There's nothing special about AI here.
People talk about, oh, you know,
how dare you talk about regulating this?
No, we regulate powerful technologies
all the time in the interests of society.
And I think this is a very important
thing that we should be looking at.
CA: It's kind of the first time we have
this superpowerful technology out there
that we literally don't understand
in full how it works.
Is the most single, most important thing
we must do, in your view,
to understand, to understand better
what on Earth is going on,
so that we least have a shot
at pointing it in the right direction?
SL: There is a lot of energy
behind capabilities at the moment
because there's a lot of value
in developing the capabilities.
I think we need to see a lot more energy
going into actual science,
understanding how these networks work,
what they're doing,
what they're not doing,
where they're likely to fail,
and understanding how we put
these things together
so that we're able to find ways
to make these AGI systems
profoundly ethical and safe.
I believe it's possible.
But we need to mobilize
more people's minds and brains
to finding these solutions
so that we end up in a future
where we have incredibly
powerful machine intelligence
that's also profoundly ethical and safe,
and it enhances and extends humanity
into, I think, a new
golden period for humanity.
CA: Shane, thank you so much
for sharing that vision
and coming to TED.
(Applause)